[MUSIC PLAYING]
TARIQ SHAUKAT: I'm really
excited to introduce
Phil and David.
And we'll have a conversation
about just the amazing success
that has been Pokemon Go.
A number of you have
these Android phones
that we handed out.
If you're not familiar
with Pokemon Go,
you can actually find the
app on the phones, as well.
Let me just ask the question.
How many folks in the room
do not know Pokemon Go?
OK.
We've got a handful here.
How many folks in the
room are avid players?
OK.
A much larger group.
There we go.
Just some sheepish looks,
but there's no need for that.
So Phil, can you tell
everyone just a little bit
about what Pokemon Go is?
It's obviously
this amazing piece
of technology, this amazing
game, but how do you
guys think about it Niantic?
PHIL KESLIN: So for those
of you who don't know,
we started Niantic as a small
little startup-style project
within Google almost
five years ago.
The goal of that
organization was
to create an
experience for people
to try and get them
off of their couches
and back in the real world
so they could experience
other people and new places.
Create exploration
apps, ways for people
to discover new things
about their community.
And what we found
along the way--
so we created two
products initially.
We created one called Field
Trip, which is a discovery app
to tell you interesting quirky
little facts about the world
around you, usually in the
location that you're standing,
and then we created the
game called Ingress,
which paired primarily
public artworks
with this real-world
location-based game.
And it's essentially,
for those of you
that haven't played it, it's
a territory capture game,
with the central point
being these public artworks.
And what we found
along the way was
that people that were
actually playing the game
were enamored with
the opportunity
to explore and learn
about their location.
And that sort of invigorated us.
Following an April
Fool's joke at Google,
capture all the Pokemon in
Google Maps, back in 2014,
we found what we thought
would be a great idea
for a real location-based game.
And so we took the same
basic Pokemon-style
capture your Pokemon
activity, and mapped it
onto the real world.
And lucky for us, the Pokemon
company was really receptive.
For them, this was like
reimagining the Pokemon game.
Actually, it was
what they originally
had imagined the
Pokemon game to be.
So adding the augmented
reality features to it
was something really
special for them.
TARIQ SHAUKAT: That's great.
Did you have any inkling when
you were creating the game
and architecting it
and what have you
about how successful
it would be?
PHIL KESLIN: We had
absolutely no idea
how successful it would be.
And I think we have a chart.
So this chart shows
you what happened.
There's an anecdote that we use.
People have always
asked us, like,
when did you know this
was going to be huge.
And we knew within the
first six hours of launch
in Australia and New Zealand.
And the reason why it was--
we launched Australia and New
Zealand with the expectation
that Australia and New Zealand
would be 4% of our
target audience.
And that's the bottom
line of that graph.
That's where we expected
the system to be operating.
The red line above it was
our worst-case scenario.
And that was 5x
our nominal usage.
And within the first six hours
of our Australia-New Zealand
launch, we had already
hit 50% of our worst case.
4% of our target was now
five-- was now half of 5x.
And you can see the rocket
ship that happened after that.
I think-- I mean,
I see Luke sitting
in the audience over here.
He's the director for customer
reliability engineering.
And I mean, he was there
with us the whole time
riding this rocket
ship, although for us I
think it was more of a
hair's on fire kind of thing.
It was a spectacular ride.
Most people don't realize
that the engineering
team that made all this happen
on our side was four engineers.
And we worked pretty much
nonstop for about six weeks
to make this a reality.
And it was always--
not only-- for us,
the surrealness was what was
happening in the real world
while this was
happening, but the fact
that every time we entered
a hangout, all of us
were just totally fried.
And on the other side of the
wall, in the Google side,
there was about
40 people sitting
on this-- on the
other side of the--
it's like they just
really helped us feel
like we were gonna make it.
So that was really kind of cool.
TARIQ SHAUKAT: That's great.
So Dave, I mentioned customer
reliability engineers before.
And Phil just talked about the
40 people on the other side.
But tell us the CRE view of
what Phil just talked about.
DAVE RENSIN: Well
the CRE view is
like 20 minutes I think
after you launched
somebody on your team
called-- actually
called-- your account rep called
Simon, who called us and said,
um, just an early heads-up,
like we'll see how this goes,
but this is kind of
trending-- what's
the word-- really upward.
So we might want
to pay attention.
And yeah, it didn't take
very long for everyone
to sort of figure out that,
OK, it's time to get going.
The funny thing was we had
spent a long time planning
to announce this CRE
thing to the world.
And it was-- and we had
gotten all the people we
needed into a team, and all sort
of the HR stuff you have to do.
And we were gonna meet for
the first time July 6th
and start on this really
hairy problem we had planned.
And then Pokemon Go
launched July 5th.
And so we started a day early.
And it was fine.
But it was awesome
validation, right,
because a thing like-- Tariq,
you and I have talked about it,
I don't know, a thousand
times-- is this relationship
that people have with
their cloud vendors
is kind of unfair,
in a way, right.
They are giving up control
of their infrastructure.
And yeah, we're giving them
a lot of innovation and speed
and cost savings, and those
are all great things on paper,
but at three in the morning
when there's trouble,
it's feel super unfair.
And there has to be this
new model, kind of this-- I
like to think of it as sort
of this new social contract
of shared fate and
shared responsibility,
where, like, Googlers or
partners that we train
and certify, which is a big
part of the growth of this,
you don't have to be
there with them at three
in the morning on the
pagers in the war rooms
taking mutual responsibility
for the success
not just of our cloud, but of
their production application.
So this was the first one.
And actually, as hard as it was,
it was an awesome experience.
I wouldn't want to do, like,
four of them in a month,
but it was a wonderful first--
TARIQ SHAUKAT: I think Phil's
with you on that, as well.
PHIL KESLIN: Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, it was a great
experience for us.
I mean, John has said
this multiple times--
he;s the CEO for Niantic-- that
I don't think that without--
I'm pretty sure without the
help of Google throughout this,
that I think the entire team
at Niantic would have imploded.
We just didn't have the
engineering resources
to make this thing happen.
And knowing-- and we
were testing limits
on not only our software,
but their software, as well.
These were capabilities
in these systems that
had never been tested before.
I mean, the largest Kubernetes
cluster in a multi-cluster-- I
remember trying to spin
that thing up one night,
and we were all just kind of
freaking out and terrified.
But having everybody--
having experts
on both sides of the wall really
made this thing a success,
and we're really, really
appreciative of it.
TARIQ SHAUKAT: What impressed
me as I was hearing from Dave
what was going on
behind the scenes
is how quickly we were able
to start pivoting together
from let's fix the
problems that we have
and let's get the
scale out there
to let's anticipate
what's going to happen.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
DAVE RENSIN: Yeah.
Luke actually has a great
saying which I love, which is--
TARIQ SHAUKAT: Luke, wave.
DAVE RENSIN: Yeah,
wave your hand.
TARIQ SHAUKAT: Wherever Luke is.
DAVE RENSIN: Which is that
forecasts are mostly useless,
but forecasting is
unbelievably helpful, right.
Just the exercise of constantly
revising how you think things
are going to grow.
And so, OK, Australia and
New Zealand, a little choppy
there for a minute.
The US was a little bit better.
We learned some stuff.
It was a little better.
And but by the time we got
ready to do Japan, right,
so we were kind of
ahead of the wave,
by the time we got ready
to do Japan, which just had
to go right-- like in
the Japanese market,
the tolerance for
hiccups is much lower
than in the US market,
or even in Europe.
And we felt we had
kind of a good handle.
We had gotten
ahead of that wave.
And that was the thing, was the
act of forecasting and planning
and going through
the operational rigor
and really looking at the
scaling failure points,
and then all the things we
kind of learned the last 15
years about what happens when
big systems go supernova fast,
and how do they break.
That was, I think, the thing
that really kind of-- that
was the linchpin of it.
PHIL KESLIN: Yeah.
Yeah, it was awesome.
I mean, it was-- I mean,
looking back on it,
the experience was-- at
times, it was disheartening.
I mean, knowing that we're
only getting three or four
hours of sleep a
night, rolling out
of bed onto your computer--
I remember going to a swim
meet one morning and
then getting paged
and then waking
up Ed, who thought
he got paged by Google
SRE, but it was actually
me calling him, is just
how whacked out our world
was for about four to six weeks.
But in the end, I
think because of all
of this and getting the
system really stable,
even with the growth
we had planned,
every single engineer
on that server team
was able to take a
two-week vacation.
So we managed to survive
that, and the team
has actually fully recovered.
And I think the world
is a great place.
TARIQ SHAUKAT: Well, it
really is a tremendous story
of Pokemon Go.
I think the engineering
feat that you pulled off
of both combining the
maps and geo with cloud
with the game designs with
the integration of a really
iconic brand and then
scaling it to a level that
is really unprecedented in
terms of how quickly you did it,
it's really just
an amazing story,
and we appreciate
being part of it.
PHIL KESLIN: I got two
statistics to share.
The first one is that, at
the beginning of September--
I don't know what
the number is now,
but we were over 500
million installs worldwide.
And we aren't even
launched worldwide yet.
And then the second one is that,
at the beginning of September,
Pokemon Go players have walked
4.6 billion kilometers, which
is more than half the distance
between Earth and Pluto,
which is--
TARIQ SHAUKAT: And there
are-- just for the record,
there are Pokemon on
Pluto, is what I'm
hearing you say at the moment.
PHIL KESLIN: Possibly.
TARIQ SHAUKAT: OK.
PHIL KESLIN: So I mean--
DAVE RENSIN: Legendary--
PHIL KESLIN: That's in 60 days,
so that's pretty phenomenal.
That's just one of the
great things about working
on stuff like this, is seeing
people benefiting from it
and creating that
social interaction,
which is really what
we set out to do.
DAVE RENSIN: It's also
got to be the world's
most successful fitness app.
TARIQ SHAUKAT: I was
just thinking that.
That's right.
DAVE RENSIN: I mean, half--
TARIQ SHAUKAT: One of the
world's most successful games,
and one of the world's
most successful--
DAVE RENSIN: I think my children
got more vitamin D over three
weeks than maybe five years.
TARIQ SHAUKAT: Terrific.
Well, thank you very much.
PHIL KESLIN: You're welcome.
TARIQ SHAUKAT: We appreciate the
partnership and you being here.
So everyone, please.
Thanks, Phil.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Dave.